oui
versailles et ses jardins lieu de balade
des beaux jours
un loisir dont profite et déjà les
courtisans des bourbons de louis xiv à
louis saez votre élan vers temps ce pour
plusieurs raisons tout d'abord parce que
il marque le temps de la vie ordinaire
de la cour d'après des saisons également
en semaine un temps rythmée dans la
semaine des jours qui sont réservées
pour la comédie des joueurs qui sont
réservées pour la musique
le but était véritablement d'être très
sélectif pour déterminer les oeuvres
marquantes et pour toujours se placer
sous le plomb de du courtisan de la
façon dont le courtisan vivait ce
divertissement le ressentais de la
chasse aux merveilleux en passant par la
comédie
l'exposition se divise en neuf
thématiques l'éclairage intimiste invite
à contempler des oeuvres issues des
collections du monde entier après une
promenade le jeu se déroulait dans le
grand appartement du roi de 18h à 22h
des boîtes de jeu évoquant le jeu de
cavaniol de la reine marie leczinska pts
qui adore et jouer aux cavaliers hall où
nous mêmes des jeux de cartes
vous pourrez vous observez par exemple
le jeu carte du roi 2016 qu'il a noté
lui même de sa main pour servir des
cartes à titre de brouillon 6 et quoi de
plus représentatif des soirées à la cour
que les bals fastueux donné tous les
samedis dans le salon de mars où la
galerie des glaces durant le règne du
roi soleil
avec cette exposition ou versailles vous
invite à entrer dans la danse